i'm so proud to finally be mrs jenkins
jeanie mai jenkins dishes all the
details of her recent wedding to rapper
jeezy
life is good that's all i can tell you
on tuesday's episode of the reel the 42
year old tv host shared some of the most
symbolic moments from her big day
the couple tied the knot in an intimate
ceremony at their home in atlanta on
march
27th in front of their immediate family
and
some of their closest friends the
symbolism started with
jeannie's dress a custom nude galia
lahav
gown which she said she envisioned right
when jeezy proposed
i knew that i wanted something very
effervescent
and nude i did not want to wear white
because we all know that white
uh symbolizes purity and that ship has
sailed shut up lonnie
but i knew i wanted nude because the
color it represents
um it represents how how skin deep i
want to be with jay
it's it's a color that represents how
transparent we are with each other
and the ceremony itself featured a whole
lot of special
meaningful moments even the wedding arch
you noticed that they weren't flowers we
chose
palm leaves which is very popular in
vietnam they represent
power and eternal life and then the
italian ruskis
on the other side of it represent
humility which is obviously before god
for genie and jeezy having peace eternal
life and humility on their big day was
important
and their rings were just one example of
how they didn't do
anything traditional i personally love
the engagement ring that jay designed
for me i couldn't imagine stacking
something to that
so i did pinky rings one for him and one
for me on my fingers
but this isn't the first time the
dancing with the stars alum has talked
symbolism and her big day i think
the main thing that really touched me
was the intention back in 2020
jeannie opened up to e.t about jeezy's
romantic proposal
in lieu of a group trip to vietnam
honoring jeannie's vietnamese heritage
which was cancelled due to the
coronavirus pandemic
jeezy brought vietnam to genie with a
date night
complete with video messages from their
friends and family
who were supposed to be on the trip i'm
really learning during this quarantine
that it's the very little things that
matter most
he could have had such a beautiful head
you know a beautiful experience of doing
it in vietnam but just doing it here
that's the symbolism to quarantine i
think for all of us and
especially for our marriage but just for
everybody is that
nothing should stop you living your life
nothing when it comes to
your goals your dreams your
relationships your
your closure in things your bonding with
yourself
and now that they're officially married
jeannie said the whole thing just feels
right
down to her new name it always felt a
little off to describe him
as my boyfriend or somebody that i was
just dating because it felt so much more
than that
so today actually with my ep rachel i
officially signed my name for the first
time with jenkins to it
and so that we can put it into the show
credit that you guys see today and that
was the first time i've
ever signed it in its official way so
i'm so proud to finally be mrs jenkins